ça devient très embêtant parce qu'en
fait ce racisme assez le racisme
ordinaire
mais est ce qui se cache en fait un
racisme fleurance et eilat en fait ça
prouve que le racisme et l attend on
revient pas à ce que vous me disait tout
le dit jimmy mohamed s'était en fait
aubervilliers aubervilliers en fait
c'est le symbole du rêve robert villiers
ses idées agressé dans le 93
voilà donc en ile de france et il ya une
forte communauté chinoise est en fait
savoir c'est qui est un asiatique qui se
faire ici tous les deux jours et sur
paris et la petite couronne un asiatique
qui se fait agresser tous les deux jours
ces attaques sont principalement des
femmes
d'accord 80% des personnes qui se font
agresser sont des femmes voilà donc
et là on voit bien que c'est du racisme
alors la france est elle raciste
marlène schiappa je vous demander de
répondre à cette question dans un
instant bonjour entendre l'avis de
laurence ça y est alors il ya des
racistes en france beaucoup et beaucoup
trop très clairement et tous les
racismes on le voit là puisque chacun va
s'exprimer il va expliquer ce qu'il a
vécu
maintenant moi j'ai répondu non parce
que j'espère bien que la majorité des
français n'est pas raciste
évidemment et surtout quand on dit la
france est raciste on pourrait penser
qu'à une organisation de l'état qui
serait raciste et c'est là où c'est
dangereux et j'ai pas envie qu'on me
dise à la jeunesse la france est raciste
parce que comment peut-on essayé de
lutter contre le racisme si déjà on dit
que le pays la france l'état la
république est raciste ça enlève tout
espoir
justement à tous les les tous les gens
qui sont issus de différents milieux de
de s'imaginer mais moi ça me gêne déjà
vous savez la question quand on vous dit
selon vous quelle est la caractéristique
d'un chinois d'un juif et tous aménagés
au débat la question mais de manière
générale aurait été gênée de répondre
parce que pour moi c'est pas une
question quand je suis avec quelqu'un je
m'en fous complètement de savoir si les
juifs si les musulmans si les noirs si
on est bien où on n'est pas bien avec
les gens on les aime qu'on les aime pas
on travaille avec eux on s'entend bien
ou pas et on a des affinités et j'espère
que la grande majeure partie des
français est dans cet état d'esprit de
se dire on s'en fout de la religion de
la couleur de l'origine d'aider des gens
avec qui on est c'est ça qu'on devrait
avoir en tête
malheureusement vous le démontrer et on
le découvre pas ça existe
il faut fermement vraiment sanctionné et
c'est bien qui est justement un
secrétariat d'état dédié
parce que c'est important le travail que
vous faites même si on sait combattu
mais il faut le dire parce que rien que
d'en parler et d'en parler régulièrement
c'est déjà faire avancer les choses